anything you want to end the video
that was [ __ ] crazy
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
what's up everybody if you're in the new
york area i'm throwing a secret wine
party tonight i just sent you a tweet to
the details
i'm going to tweet it out in a couple
hours hosting it at 11 00 p.m in a
secret location somewhere here in new
york city when i fire it
come into the city check us free wine
free empathy hang out a little meet up
should be fun i'll see you then
[Music]
what's up man
what are you called yeah
super nimitz
chris 16 that's good bro what's up fam
chris what's good bro
it's
how many people are here already uh
there's like one twenty i think there's
like 2 000 people that show up well
i know that
we're where are we hi how are you
claire thank you hi nice to meet you
thank you so much
show me some stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it i want to be the biggest
advertiser in the better perspective
bit bigger than facebook good for you
because my co-founder annie had a
product
i think we're going over here oh
good one thank you
nice to meet you guys thanks for coming
big sports car fan i hope you get the
jets one day i just want to take a
picture man i don't want to waste any of
your time who's got it right here
how are you doing who's my friend
how are you i'm good 16 year old artist
that i've known
digitally for like six months
and just did an open edition with nifty
gateway like just kill him caleb where
do you live washington washington state
state yes
i'm glad you're here absolutely real
pleasure to meet you i got it
yesterday two days ago
mark zuckerberg would like to be on your
podcast
and i did it yesterday i can't wait for
you to watch something actually record
it oh it's amazing does randy know that
very
you're
important
to love it
i want to take a picture with him
i don't know if you remember that i dude
i
tyler and andy may i was a little bit
out of it but like it's good to see you
again
thank you pleasure all right
such a pleasure absolutely really good
to meet you man
you're always so busy bro
maybe we can get a zoom in sometimes i
would love that one before you're just
mobbed
i love you more are you
realistically like i got into nfts after
i had a really bad accident and i lost
like the use of my body so you know such
an expression i'm so glad you're getting
it out there i really appreciate it real
pleasure i'm glad you're here thank you
great night thank you too before this
gets crazy
all right good brother how are you hi
gary how are you it's great to see you
how you been good good welcome yeah
it's all right awesome
awesome you signed something for me i
can't my board
let's go
yes i know exactly who you are
when did we meet
hold on i got a prayer right now okay
something just happened okay
all right all right all right
give me something give me that there it
is i don't need the money give me that
give me that
give me that that was [ __ ] good
that moment where my head went i don't
know where you went you you were sitting
across from me i saw you yeah
i remember
blown away by that that was amazing give
me something for that
give me something i'm always like
wondering like when i do it do you
actually remember right
give me something on that first
[Music]
let's gather everybody from vayner and
somehow systematically try to get as
many people back here as possible yeah
cool
like gather more vayner and then like
got it
oh yeah
how are you i need your help
i need vayner to help get as many people
back there as possible
ben
let's start getting it set up and open
thanks karen
here we are
web four though
when what the web for wine party all
right
amazing congratulations
by the way thank you brother thank you i
pre-ordered 12 copies of your book thank
you brother so i'm just
going to share it i'm going to donate to
libraries give it to my friends and uh
you know i'll see you inside
saying documentary
thanks for being in my wu tang
documentary thank you bro remember of
course
of course you gave us a great interview
thank you brother good to see you thank
you for selling my cousin his company
back for a dollar you're welcome i
appreciate that i always tell people
you're solid today thank you very much
you're welcome of course nicoria of
course yeah thank you brother
i think so because this is not going to
get crowded
are you good
i want to help
i want to get in the mix
thank you for coming
thank you for coming
[Music]
you're asking i brought something for
you thank you my friend it's an nfc that
i made this is the physical i can air
drop you the digital that's [ __ ]
amazing so i got this for you this is
for you man thank you to bring it out
here thank you man
what's your name joey joey it's a real
pleasure absolutely man i just wanted to
make sure i got this in your hands
i got it i'm gonna put it in my pocket
thank you so much real quick
thank you so much welcome bro oh here
are the t-shirts what's up gary hi
how are you good to see you
how are you thank you great
mom
yesterday
yesterday yes you took the phone and
she's like
a celebrity because
let's go dude
for me
one [ __ ] life living always always
always living
yes sir thank you say you're welcome bro
yo
[Music]
who wants shirts
that's good let's go what's good you
want shirts
let's go bam
let's go
gary the best three minutes
friend of course
so
thank you i've been trying to follow you
for like a couple
do me a favor can you get her connected
to andy okay all right
she's
what's good bro
it's kind of a cool shirt thank you man
thank you so much you helped a huge fan
got it got it
i saw this photo you did the calligraphy
i saw it on twitter
yeah you can
take a picture
thank you so much you're welcome
thank you drock
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
[Applause]
what's that what if you could believe
everything on the internet that'd be
amazing
but that's not how humans work gary what
the internet's just the mirror of the
humans okay imagine if you build a news
network
what's that network
that doesn't make it real gary oh my god
i'll be excited if you do it how's it
going very good how are you good to see
you days how are things good
great to see you here we have a question
yeah it's always ingredients you know
it's intense it's execution it's
circumstance it's a lot of [ __ ]
we're really good at it everyone is here
to support you thank you i'm so glad you
guys are here i
i just wrote this book and it was
published yesterday with t-pain my name
is maxwell i'm a mixologist
thank you bro thank you this is first
thing i've given to anybody thank you
for doing that yeah i really do i hope
you enjoy it man what's up everyone
[Music]
watching monkeys i got 30 i got 82 of
them i got five i'm not gonna make it
you're gonna make it
[Laughter]
okay gary i'm literally just here to
give you this gift you're very sweet
thank you but don't say cabana yeah this
is from fancy
yeah thank you it's good to see you
you're welcome
and welcome gary gary you remember the
beginning of the year when you uh had to
scrape all those winery sites before
nfts yes yes
thank you so much for the town hall
it's like it made me very emotional and
i'm very appreciative for everything
you're doing and the realness of what
you're saying thank you for saying that
but i really appreciate it thank you
that's awesome yeah he's good for you
how you doing bro
what's good dude
hey ben good
nice to meet you it's good
that's good bro you know what
what's up fam yeah
what's up bro
how are you yeah the new project has 10
features
normally no features all 10 feet all
features
hey
yep
bro you got five more [ __ ] lives
and i was telling daddy oh right here um
you know what keyglot
like what we're doing with draftkings
and stuff like he has no red tape and
has memphis unlocking we just shot the
video at the uh castle in memphis you
know what i mean for tresco trey and uh
and my and my sports firm we just uh we
just uh signed jalen duran
so we're gonna be in memphis a lot so
i'm gonna come through we're gonna i'm
gonna come for at least two three games
in memphis i'm looking at the knicks
schedule i want to come through when
they play the grizz so you want to go to
the shot again
when on what
i'm out next week i'm going to cali for
some [ __ ] but i'm going to be coming
through
you know what i'm going to bring you
i'll bring you
i'm coming for at least two three games
for jayla yeah we'll be walking in
memphis
mike knows more about bielsa than you
think
straight up
ah man i'm cheering for you heavy breath
out let's make a deal i treat you to the
[ __ ] game contributing
what about super bowl maybe i can book
you know maybe you know i'm about to
start booking talent for super bowl
it's in la this year yeah the way you
wrap clock and your fan base we can do
so much [ __ ] with you like sometimes the
brands might need it a little cleaner
than normal but yeah exactly you know
you do not you don't have the red tape
bro we're just doing like we're just
trying to do cool [ __ ] with people have
influence like yourself man
we're also in a whole different place
than we were even two years ago we got
brands really starting to put out paper
because they trust us and like there's
some real [ __ ] to be done
bro i really cheer for you know that you
can hit me anytime especially hit me
when you're down
for real i'll bring you right back up
real quick
and that bart chain's crazy
that simpson do it to him like that all
right i gotta get in there bro
fellas
take care of yourselves
good bro hey it's your name ethan real
pleasure
it's good to see you again all right
we'll talk later yeah look he got the
eight ball on me
everyone said gratitude
but i just want to let you know that i
am a dev
and i want to be the next year i'm gonna
do it because i shoot straight
but i need endorsement i need help i
didn't get an endorsement that's not my
problem i'm sorry about that but here i
am
[Music]
but listen listen it's even how you got
put down bro
of course
what are you talking about
bro this is how you [ __ ] this is why i
[ __ ] hit you seven years ago i know
you see [ __ ] the way i see [ __ ]
you early you see [ __ ]
it's a huge tower
i was homeless here in new york city
four years back and kanye had discovered
me and you know i was homeless for a
week
you know your words are just
miami friends we [ __ ] made it
let's go
i'll see you guys soon
thank you thank you i'll be with you one
second
i can't control it you can't be here
hey but i want to share something with
you i would never know who you are and
hear about you like i was waking up so
early yesterday
to listen to you because you came into
the nft and i'm being honest so i would
never say thank you so thank you what's
your name
m-a-a-m-a
thank you
and to
listen to you because you know i'm
telling you if it's voted for the nfd i
would never know people it's beautiful
thank you thank you for coming i thought
it was doing the right thing in my
companies in my crew because everything
felt safe because i wouldn't confront
but then i would just fire people
and then i realized everyone was
actually scared because they didn't
really know where they sat me
you know sometimes how the subconscious
becomes the conscious
you know how that happens
but you've brought so many people to
nfps that i can't deny it i appreciate
it i'm still not going to buy any
friends i'm going to stick to the pump
but thank you for bringing you know
people we got to give you
[ __ ] credit what creditors do i
appreciate a little selfie i'd love so i
could tell all my friends to the haters
that that garyvee actually could take a
selfie with me hey chef how are you i'm
great
have a great day congrats on your phone
and the way that you got into christie's
you you slid in
[Music]
worry about the [ __ ] blockchain later
about the blockchain
get get get get leverage of having a
community everything will work itself
out
tick tock window for virality is going
to close the next few years [ __ ] go
as hard as you can on that platform
gotcha got it
[Music]
i know you've seen the project that i'm
currently working on for the end of teas
and i really look forward to our
conversation in the future i can't wait
thanks for being here
thanks for coming out really why did you
decide to wear this shirt today
because
this whole scene
makes me reminds me of what this was
back in 2007
it was the best
[Music]
see how much you
each person thank you i see you i just
met with the musician who asked you a
question at another event that i
connected with on twitter and he's like
that's what he told me gary he was every
single person
and that's a real like real like you
know like
brother
you know like my brother and we'll see
you at peacock you know from day one day
brother
and we've been missing like we missed
our flight to get to the token soft
event so thank you the way i do
everything is i don't give a [ __ ] about
everybody's road map
[ __ ] about wire frames i gotta take [ __ ]
how can i like practically like move
forward with this mindset of like you
know
this is my future this is my goal that i
want to like i fell in love with just
providing people what stuff what's
stopping you
[Music]
developers and like not even developers
just ideas who's a developer now i got
in i got into space
i got into this space a couple months
ago
there we go we're good next
yeah thank you
the reason i did that was you can find a
developer the developers aren't the
problem so what would the problem be if
i was to be like uh the problem is
either a lack of patience or a lack of
confidence
and and the lack of confidence usually
comes from actually caring what
everybody here thinks
well then if you don't give a [ __ ] then
just do it i appreciate you this is
[ __ ] 20 years of putting out a ton of
[ __ ] love asking for nothing it
doesn't happen like that so i think the
way you have to do is build a community
like where's the discord for the project
it's
ready it's not live yet you know like
that that's the reps that's like
thinking about doing push-ups you're
gonna have to do them right
so is this for us no then we're good
okay good
thank you you're welcome good luck
in terms of the push-ups for the discord
any specific advice yeah launch a
discord and then [ __ ] put out a tweet
and be like yo join my discord and three
people show up because you only have 200
followers there we go you know and it's
just [ __ ] step by step step by step
but it takes time okay let's just say no
i have been building steps i believe you
i believe you i have no concept to that
to you not doing that the problem is to
get to a place to sell 10 000 units of
something
takes like time
all right thank you gary appreciate it
budweiser forget about for a second
there's a bigger conversation which is
you can
but people aren't you want to
people will
but it's early
like it's early yeah like 98 of people
have no idea what the [ __ ] any of us are
talking about right now right 98 of them
have not even a concept my grandma
doesn't get it forget about your grandma
the grandma is the easy thing to say
80 of your 30 year old friends don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
so i think a lot of people are pretty
much showing their timing on living in
the metaverse like oculus is
disproportionately the biggest winner
and it's still small
and it's disproportionately the leader
everybody's buying up [ __ ] real
estate in the metaverse on some world
that's not even going to be here that's
like buying real estate on friendster
to 10 years before [ __ ] twitter the
brands are going to want to bring their
assets into this world right they want
to own that the the ip of the jacket of
the shoes of the hat of the glasses
they're going to need to bring that into
the metaverse and to me that is 3d and
you don't see 3d everywhere you're not
seeing it
that's fine
and like i couldn't agree with you more
but by the time it hits enough scale for
those two [ __ ] that were on stage
with me to give a [ __ ]
you're gonna be [ __ ] 73 years old no
way no way
dude it's gonna take a long time before
let me ask you a question based on your
reaction
when do you think 100 million people are
going to be living in the metaverse for
five hours a day when do you think a
hundred million people will be living
for five hours a day in oculus or vr
devices
i'll give it 10 years and i'm willing to
bet a decade that's fine that's that's
to me is a good number so the question
is i feel comfortable with that answer
right it could be we're not sure could
be seven could be 12
[ __ ] gonna do for the next 10 years
buy hold and build that's fine then
that's amazing but you can't rely on the
brands
you go buy and build and we'll see you
in 10 years is what they're going to say
if 23 year olds knew what it felt like
to be 45
and feel this young they would slow
their [ __ ] down they're so in a rush
to show everybody else that they made it
that they put so much pressure on
themselves for no [ __ ] reason
yeah
and how did you come up with reference
in 2018 i was going to make toys to put
on people's desks because i was getting
so many dms and emails during the day
from people being upset at work that i
thought if i made little characters like
patient panda and empathy elephant back
then in 18 i already had them
if it was on their desk they wouldn't
need to go to the phone and see my
content they would just look at the
character and maybe say [ __ ] it and feel
better
then i got sidetracked then covet
happened and then when the nft thing hit
me i was like [ __ ] it i'm gonna go back
to that thesis
and create characters
i can only scale so much as me as a
human this is all crazy and amazing but
like i'm just one dude but my characters
could be [ __ ] mickey mouse they could
be [ __ ] pikachu and so
i knew what i i know and i knew and i
know what i want the world to talk about
and i knew that if i created it in
character form the scalability would be
huge so that's how i came up with it
nice i like that thanks cheers who here
bought the book right yeah
[ __ ] yes i i really got something for
you
i really do i'm okay give us a little
hint though nope
[Music]
this is for the community we out here we
are [ __ ] out at night
[Applause]
slowly though your lack of patience is
[ __ ] you up
i'm ready for your boss what's up thank
you for coming out bro of course thank
you thank you for coming out thanks gary
appreciate it
you do so much for the community your
inspiration for me
thank you for you know the podcast
really changed my life my guy thank you
so much
you're welcome all right fellas thank
you everybody thank you so much for
staying out real pleasure thank you
have a great rest of the week
frankie i love you bro talk later
thank you thank you thank you thanks for
everything
i'm so proud
thank you i will i'll look forward all
right ready
thank you very much thank you thank you
see you next year good to see you thank
you everybody one to ten what do you
think of the guerrilla marketing
of your abyss
the bus we bootstrapped this we're broke
kids from the woods
a solid 8.8 8.8
thank you
anything you want to end the video
that was [ __ ] crazy
youtube what's up it's garyvee first of
all thank you so much i hope you're
doing super well during these times uh i
also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you